welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz
and this is another episode of the 15
minutes with a mentor
series which we're releasing in line
with the recruitment mentors community
opening
and in this series really simply we're
going to ask some of the mentors from
inside the community
seven questions in 15
minutes so today i'm really pleased to
be uh joined by
john guest and before i ask you the
first question john why don't you
introduce yourself
uh those that may not know who you are
and we'll get into it
yeah thanks hisham um yeah thanks for
inviting me to be a part of this
so i'm john guest i have been in
recruitment now since 2007
you probably see a few gray hairs on the
sides but they weren't there when i
started
but um i work for a business called
harper harrison
i'm the vice president of executive
search so i run a brand
focused on the real estate market and we
focus on the us primarily
texas but we've also picked up some
searches
in the surrounding states good to be
with you
amazing so first question
what was your biggest challenge in 2020
how did you overcome it and what did you
learn from it
so wow one challenge in 2020
i think the biggest challenge for for me
was
the first lockdown um
when nurseries shot having a
two-year-old in the house
my wife working full-time as well as me
and
you know we were trying to make it up as
we went along and it didn't really work
for the first
few weeks maybe a month to be honest it
was
kind of carnage who's looking after him
who's on a call these calls clash
it was just completely set up in the
wrong way
for whatever reason i don't know why we
didn't kind of think of this earlier
but i think what i learned was we then
started sitting down
every night or every morning and kind of
really mapping out
the day and trying to get one day in
advance two days in advance so that we
didn't book any calls that clashed
sounds really basic
um who's working when who's looking
after william when
and just try and make sure that
expectations were managed i think
in any relationship be that in the
office
outside of the office all the breakdown
comes from
mismanaged expectations so we were
definitely mismanaging
each other's expectations about how much
time we could give to our job
um so that's probably my biggest
challenge and then my biggest
learning um and after we got the system
working properly
life became definitely not easy but a
lot easier
i love that yeah i've definitely getting
better at communicating with your other
half is a great thing to get better at
that that's amazing that's something you
haven't had to do before necessarily you
communicate on everything but you
haven't necessarily had to work together
at the same time like working on a
weekend really
um yeah but hey we got that the the
second question
sort of follows on onto this but sort of
i'm always keen to hear this from people
but basically what
working from home tip could you share
with other recruiters that
has had a massive impact on productivity
so it might be what you just shared but
what
sort of tip or thing comes up for you
that's really impacts your productivity
do you think
i think it's easy
it's been said by a lot of people that
the lines between work
and outside of work really blur when
you're working at home which
to me isn't necessarily a bad thing like
if you enjoy what you do
and you're consciously working longer
hours because that's what you really
want to do
and there's nothing wrong with that but
i think you know if you divide like the
pie chart up
and it's 100 work it's probably not
you're not going to be as productive
during that time
so for me the biggest um when i've been
feeling my best is when i've had
time for life admin so before i start
the day i'll try and get
some things done give get the
endorphines going something that i'm in
control of
in this world where we're not in control
of a huge amount right now
whether that's i don't know clearing out
a room tidying up something
cleaning like sorting out the garden
whatever um
and then probably feeding into that like
building in some time to either go for a
walk
exercise like i've spoke to my wife this
morning twelve o'clock we're gonna go
for a walk so that's agreed both of us
i know i can build my day around that
rather than trying to fit it in
because if you try and fit the rocks in
after you've already put the sand in i
guess there's no room
so it's trying to think what is actually
important so the days when i've
exercised
the day when i'm feeling better about
myself i find
even if i'm working an hour less i get
so much more done
yeah really like that so this is
interesting
i know obviously you're sort of in the
process of building out a new market but
what
what has been the most effective way for
you to win business in the last 12
months
um i wish there was one way history i
really do
and just do that every day um i think
the best way to build out a new market
in my opinion
is to try and come up with
ways to give to people in the first
instance that doesn't just
involve you yes if you're taking good
candidates to market
and you're doing that effectively where
it actually
makes sense to someone to open that
email and you can clearly you've read
their website you haven't just bombed it
out to 50 people that might be relevant
might not that can work and get people
on the phone but
i think mapping companies that you want
to work with
connecting with as many people on
linkedin
so that they you're you're kind of
present in their world when you do
connect with them dropping them a
message
trying to make it personal to their
situation or something that you've seen
on their profile than just trying to
start a conversation
and then whether they come back to you
or not there's probably some recognition
when you then pick up the phone
so they don't instantly think oh this is
a sales call
they think oh yeah i do vaguely remember
that actually and that buys you that
first 10 20 seconds to actually start
the conversation
that's probably the most effective way
if they're someone who isn't an owner of
a business
you can head hunt them you can talk
about their own situation you can kind
of
talk about them people which people love
and then
turn the conversation later on to find
out about their team and how they're
feeling about this year and
plans for hiring but i think going in to
talk about them
or offering them something of value
first
is definitely the best way nice i like
that
so interested to hear this from you what
what habit of hobby did you start in
2020 that you're going to continue in
2021
so i um quite early in the lockdown went
out bought a turbo trainer for my bike
so um it's uh what's it called
uh the kicker snap now if you you
actually connect your own bike to it so
as long as you have a bike
the back wheel snaps in and you have
like a
dyno on the back and it's bluetooth
so you use a program called zwift
right so it's a bit like peloton in that
lots of people use it
but it's a bit more like a computer game
where you can go through london
new york paris oh nice i'm not on
commission by the way
but there's races there's open events
they did the tour de france on there so
i rode a stage of the tour de france
that was amazing
nearly passed out but it was good like
pretty cool
a few of the guys i work with so one of
the guys in my team's on there so you
can like join up and you can ride
together
um it's just great you've got different
worlds different events
it's like gamification of exercise
ift it's quite a big community now
they've definitely done well
out of lockdown but um i've actually i
think i've done about
1300 kilometers now on there and it's
all
it's it's a smart trainer so if you go
up a hill you know that you're going up
a hill
you know you have to adjust your gears
it's it's interactive hard work
they've got um like the out the zwift on
there which is
the equivalent of the out the hues which
is one of the biggest climbs on the tour
de france so
it's it's pretty cool and then do you do
you think
i don't know are you then going to turn
that into like actually biking
i've been out bike a few times as well
um but i think
when you're short for time you know you
don't have to get ready
yeah you just jump on it and go and when
you finish just jump straight in the
shower and then you're back at your desk
so
you can kind of fit in and lunch break
really easily
and you also don't have to worry about
snow or getting hit by a car
yeah um interested to hear this which do
you think is better the first coffee in
the morning or the first pint post work
on a friday
definitely the first coffee working at
home um
yeah i'm almost done dry january now so
um you know beer is
i've actually quite enjoyed not not
drinking and having a bit of a detox and
feeling like have a bit clearer thought
um yeah
ask me again in six months
um love that right so the next question
i want is
more of a bit of a scenario okay so i
want to give you this scenario that
recruiters probably find themselves in
quite a lot so i just want to share
i want you to share with us sort of how
you would approach this scenario so
a particular business that you've had on
your target client list
for over a year um you've had like you
mentioned earlier you've had a couple of
touch points
with different hiring managers in this
organization so they may have received a
message from you on linkedin you may
have
dropped them an email even an inmail
just there's been
several touch points and but through
your candidate network you managed to
get one of the hiring managers contact
numbers someone that you have a good
relationship with you call that number
you call that person
and the hiring manager picks up they say
hello who is this
what do you say what would your approach
be
so i'll be i mean i'm building a new
market
has allowed me to experiment with a lot
of these things so um
my mind is now ticking over as to which
ones work best but i'd probably
say there's two am i allowed to give two
yeah yeah
absolutely there's two scenarios that i
think
i would use that have a good level of uh
engagement so
if someone is a ceo or an owner
or a partner where you know that
actually they're not going to really
move jobs necessarily they're running
their own thing
um you've kind of taken that angle away
i would probably have approached them
about
a roundtable event that we're putting
together so we've
we've hosted or hosting in a couple of
weeks our first roundtable event for
talent leaders we're also doing one for
leaders in our space in this in texas
so approaching them about the event so
telling them what we do
but also saying as part of our role as
executive search business
in your market by hosting virtual
roundtable event
bringing together leaders in the space
to talk about some of their challenges
share best practice and build a
community
that can take some of the ideas back to
their business is that the kind of thing
that you'd like to get involved in was
that the kind of thing that sounds
interesting
just a really open question just to get
them talking
and i think most people are deciding in
that first 30 seconds whether you're
actually worth listening to whether you
can bring value to their world
and not always the case but the more
senior people get
the more engagement they get the more
they get approached so actually their
filter has to be stronger
and you have to bring more value to even
get past that first hurdle
so that can be a good way of getting
them talking
if it's someone that's a director or a
vice president or a senior vice
president or even a cfo
i probably head hunt them i'd probably
say
like hisham john guest i'm a headhunter
within the real estate sector
i've been looking at your profile really
impressed with your experience and i
wondered how much of an open mind you
kept
towards an opportunity that would
present a forward step if i had like a
search that i was working on i might
then
touch on we've actually got a project
that we're working on for a business i'd
love to share with you
is now a bad time should we arrange a
time to speak
and from that you're not really giving
them
an out eight seven or eight out of ten
people probably keep an open mind
even if they don't they're probably
intrigued to find out
what you're working on and what's
happening in the market so from that
point on you can then
find out a bit more about them yeah i
think that's the easiest way to open it
up
nice really like that's great great
advice so final question
is imagine i was a recruiter who's
set their goals for 2021 fully motivated
um hopefully i've written down those
goals because that's going to increase
my chances of actually making them a
reality
um but what and i'm sure you may have
been having this advice to yourself or
with your colleagues but like what
advice would you give me or for the
recruiters listening
if if we if i wanted to have the best
possible chance of actually achieving
the goals that i've set this year
what would your advice be to me
stay in your lane
that's that's been my advice to a lot of
people it's been my advice to myself
and we i got sucked far too much into
the outside world at the first lockdown
and you know watching the news all the
time and getting addicted to the bbc
news website and refreshing to see what
happened and none of that's going to set
you up to be the best
you can be in a day in my opinion you're
going to load yourself with
with anxiety and you're going to be
worrying about things that ultimately
you can't control now i'm not suggesting
for any minute we just forget what's
happening in the outside world because
clearly
there's there's you know tough times
right but i do believe that
you limit that to a certain part of the
day
or a certain time and if a news story is
big enough it will find you anyway
that's something that i've been
practicing and i promise you it works
news finds me
if people talk about it in your whatsapp
groups with your mates
people that you do end up bumping into
or whatever you do turn on the tv to
watch something else and you see it so
it's not like you have to necessarily go
and find it i think staying in your lane
focusing on the things you can control
focusing on the wins that you've had
and the success stories and businesses
that are doing well surround yourself
with people
that are on that same path because i
think we all know that misery loves
company
so i think just staying in your lane
would 100 be my
advice for any year and especially 2021.
now great advice john 7 questions 15
minutes
nailed it thank you so much